Viktor frankl was put through some of the most horrific struggles a human being
could imagine,
but he never lost hope and he used his experiences.
Do you continue as work helping other people find meaning in their lives?
Frankel story is one of strength of hope and to have a man who made an impact on
the world,
so let's don't even into it.
In 1905 Viktor Frankl was born the middle child of a Jewish family in Vienna.
His parents were government employees and the family was comfortable.
Then world war one hit like so many other families at that time.
The frankels had to contend with better poverty.
He and his siblings even at to go from farm to farm begging for food.
As the war progressed,
as a young child,
Frankel showed interest and aptitudes and the medical profession as how many,
three years old he wanted to become a doctor.
Then at four years old,
he had the realization that every human has to go through and that's the one day
he would die.
Still just a toddler.
Frankel's lifework had already started to take shape.
By the time he was in high school.
Frankl was already studying psychology and philosophy.
He even gave a speech called on the meaning of life in 1921 two years before his
graduation,
and when the answer write a final paper for graduation,
what else would he write on?
But the psychology of philosophical sought by the time he had turned 20 he had
already been in touch with doctor Sigmund Freud Frankel wrote Froyd to latter
earns included a copy of one of his own papers in s more impressively,
the famous doctor then requested that frank allow him to publish one of the
papers that Franklin had written later recalling the incidents.
Frankel still sounded like he couldn't believe the incidents even after decades
of building up his own Korea.
Can you imagine what a 16 year old's mind of Sigmund Freud asked to have a paper
he wrote published.
Then three years after that correspondence,
Frankl was walking in a park in Vienna and encountered a man who looked
familiar.
Frankel went up to him and asked if he was Sigmund Freud.
He was and when frank called began to introduce himself,
Freud recited Frankel's addressed to him.
Freud had been so impressed by Franco just even as the years passed,
he never forgot the letter that he received from the young man apart from
psychology Frankel also spent his high school years in mass in politics.
He began his involvement with the young socialist workers as a team and even
rose to become presidents of the organization in 1924 with a string of
accomplishments in the field of psychology already achieved during his teen
years.
Frankel headed to the University of Vienna to formally study,
has chosen fields of neurology and psychiatry.
Initially he based his studies in the theories and ideas that Sigmund Freud had
advanced,
but over time he began moving more towards Alfred Adler's ideas.
Even after moving on from Freud's ideas.
Frankel who kept a bust of the preeminence Viennese psychoanalyst in his office.
Freud developed psychoanalysis and added to that is with the developments of the
inferiority complex and frankly it became the third of these giants of
psychology in Vienna as he develops a search for meaning called logo therapy.
As a key part of the study of the human psyche,
but before he became a world renowned psychiatrist,
Frankl was making a difference much closer to him as a student.
He began actively putting into practice what he was learning and the theories
that he was developing moving beyond just academic interest in the human psyche,
Frankl was able to literally save lives during his time as a medical student.
Franco noticed a disturbing trends among students in Austria and high schools
when grades were reported at the end of the school term,
there was a spike in suicides,
Frankel spearheaded and initiative to provide free counseling to students with
an emphasis on helping them at the end of the school term.
Incredibly.
The very first year that Frankel's program was implemented was also the first
time in recent memory that the wind,
no students suicides in Vienna with proven success in suicide prevention.
Frankl moved on to become the head of the Vienna Psychiatric Hospitals Female
Suicide Prevention Program from 1933 to 1937 he worked with thousands of women
who were in danger of committing suicide.
Then in 1937 he opened his own private practice,
but well,
a year later Frankel's world,
it would become upper route it.
In 1938 Germany invaded Austria.
Frankl was Jewish and under the Nazi regime,
he was not permitted to treat Arion patients.
The Rothschild Hospital in Vienna was the only place where Jewish patients could
be treated,
so Frankl was called upon to users talents them as the head of the neurological
department.
While working at Rothschild,
frank was also waiting to hear news that could lift him out of the terrifying
situation that so many European Jews were in.
He had applied for a visa to the United States and just needed his lottery
number to be called.
Well,
he was one of the lucky ones.
There's a lottery number came up before Pearl Harbor and the United States,
his entrance into the war,
but Frankel's decisions and leave Austria.
It wasn't easy.
The visa is applies only to Franco and not to any other member of his family,
his parents and siblings that'd be left behind in an even scarier environments,
and Franklin knew their fate was likely to end up in a concentration camp.
Frankel,
he knew he had a choice to make and he decided to ops on a higher power.
It's going to them in the right direction.
When he came across a fragments of a stone in his parents' house,
he knew he had found the answer.
I was looking for the state.
It wasn't just any old stone.
It was a piece of the 10 commandments that had one student,
a local synagogue burned down by the Nazis.
The synagogue was reduced to rubble and frankly,
his father had picked up a piece of the stone for the family to have and it's
what was the piece that he just happened to pick up?
Well,
it depicted a portion of the commandments honor thy father and mother to Franco.
This meant his decision was absolutely clear.
He would stay in Austria with his family and to be right alongside them as they
dealt with the Horace.
That the Nazis had brought upon them and Franco.
Well,
he knew the horrors analyses were capable of and he and his wife Tilly were
married in 1941 and the two of them wanted to have children,
but Jewish couples,
they were not allowed to have children.
Frankel's wife conceived,
but she was not allowed to give birth.
She was forced to have an abortion and then in 1942 what Franklin fears when it
came true,
he,
his wife and his parents were arrested.
They were initially sent a Thespian stars,
a camp in Czechoslovakia.
There.
Frankl did what he could to help others running a clinic,
helping new prisoners cope with the drastic shock of entry into a camp and
establishing a suicide watch.
Frankel,
his wife and his mother survived.
They're seeing stars that his father did not.
He died after any six months in the camp in 1944 Frankl was ordered to
Auschwitz.
His mother was also ordered to go,
but his wife was not,
but she was simply not going to go without her husbands.
She volunteered to be moved to Auschwitz.
The two ended up separators.
In the end.
However,
upon arriving at Auschwitz till he was pushed onward to Bergen Belsen while
Frankl and his mother were capped at Auschwitz,
at first,
they in 1500 others were kept in a shared men to hold only one sick that many
people,
the ground was bare and the prisoners were forced to squat for days while they
subsisted only on a small piece of bread.
From here,
the prisoners were directed into two lines,
one's the gas chamber and one two years of labor and misery,
but at least survival for the time being.
Franco's mother was executed in the gas chambers and Frankl himself by the
escapes that fate.
Frankl was audited to the left line,
but it's defined the order and stepped into the other group.
He later discovered that the left blind was the line towards the gas chamber and
then certain death.
He was one of the few to survive Auschwitz.
1.3 million people were sent through the gates of Auschwitz and 1.1 million of
them died.
Those who didn't die right away in the gas chamber suffered through deaths
caused by starvation disease,
exhaustion from forced labor and even medical experiments.
Though outfits was the site of a huge number of atrocities.
Many others suffered in camps throughout Europe.
Frankel's wife was one of those who met their fate in a different camp from our
husbands,
tinny perished at the hands of the Nazis at the camp known as Bergen Belsen and
Frankl did not learn.
She had died until after the war had ended and he was liberated in 1945
throughout his time,
suffering in the camps not knowing Tillys face,
he was able to find meaning and is a level of comfort in the knowledge of love.
He thought of her throughout his ordeal in the concentration camps and
recognizing how that helps him.
He started to theorize what love meant for human life.
He needs to set,
I'll just thinking and his famous work,
man's search for meaning.
For the first time in my life.
I saw the truth as it is set into song.
By so many poets proclaimed as the final wisdom by so many fingers.
The truth that to love is the ultimate and highest goal to which man can aspire.
Then I grasped the meaning of the greatest secret that human poetry and human
thought and belief have to impart.
The Salvation of man is through love and in love.
When he was in the camps,
Frankl had to distract himself from the reality of what he was going through.
He saw death and suffering up close.
He was forced into cattle cars,
forced demarche,
contracted typhoid fever and was separated from his most beloved family members.
So now you might be wondering,
well,
what was one way he pushed himself to survive this?
He explains,
I repeatedly tried to distance myself from the misery that surrounded me by
externalizing it.
I remember marching one morning from the camp to the worksite,
hardly able to bear the hunger,
the coals,
and his pain of my frozen and festering feet,
so swollen.
My situation seems bleak,
even hopeless.
Then I imagined that I stood at the lectern and a large,
beautiful,
warm and bright hall.
I was about to give a lecture to an interested audience on psychotherapeutic
experiences in a concentration camp.
The actual title.
I later used in the imaginary lecture I reported the things I am now living
through.
Believe me,
ladies and gentlemen,
at that moment,
I could not dare to hope that Sunday,
it was to be my good fortune to actually give such a lecture.
Franco Wilson made a point of finding a lesson in goodness and survival in the
suffering he endured and the suffering he witnessed.
These themes informed his life's work.
We who lived in concentration camps can remember the men who walked through the
huts,
comforting others,
giving away their last piece of bread.
They may have been few in number as they offer sufficient proof that everything
can be taken from a man,
but one thing,
the last of the human freedoms to choose one's attitude in any given set of
circumstances to choose one's own way.
In April of 1945 Frankl had a welcome sight,
American soldiers,
they had come to liberate.
To the concentration camps,
meaning Frankl was once again a free man.
He did not have family left save for a sister who had escaped to Australia.
He was essentially starting new in the wells that's he had his ideas,
his education,
and his professional experience.
So he put his ideas into writing.
In only nine days.
During the summer of 1945 Frankel dictated a full manuscript.
The result was man's search for meaning,
a description of what life was like in the concentration camps and the come
inside and realizations.
Frankel has during his time as a prisoner about the need for meaning and human
life and the role of suffering in the world.
The book served as the basic outline for longer therapy.
The idea of positive by Frankl.
There's men are most driven by a search for meaning.
By 1946 he was fully back into his professional weld running Vvn,
a poly clinic of neurology.
By in 1948 he has earned a phd in philosophy.
He began teaching at the University of Vienna where he would remain a professor
until 1990 after he was released from the concentration camps.
Frankl also remarried in 1947 he married Eleanor Schwinns Mans,
the two edit daughters together as an adult's Frankel's daughter.
I followed in her famous father's footsteps and it's became a child
psychiatrist,
though he was teaching at the University of Vienna.
Frankl stitchings soon began to make a worldwide impact with Freud and Adler as
his predecessors of Vienna had already established itself as a center of
Psychological and psychiatric study,
Freud and Adler,
where the first and second schools of Viennese psychotherapy and Frankel's ideas
about man's needing meaning in his life became the third.
By the mid 1950s Frankl was being invited to speak at universities around the
world.
He has also created to the Austrian Medical Society for psychotherapy and headed
up the organization.
In 1955 the University of Vienna,
they do a full professor and by 1961 he was serving as visiting professor at
Harvard and his ideas were being cemented in the minds of those studying
psychotherapy in the United States.
His academic career continued to grow as he lectured at over 200 universities
and was awarded an astonishing 29 honorary degrees.
Though,
man,
search for meaning was by far his best known work.
Francl also wrote and published 39 other books during his lifetime in 1970 he
was honored by his peers and they created the Viktor Frankl Institute.
Among his academic work,
francl still worked with patients.
One of his methods was to ask the most depressed patients.
He encountered a seemingly simple six word question.
Why do you not commit suicide from hair?
Frankl would discover what it was that the patient actually found joy in what
made their life worth living.
In other words,
what the meaning was in their life.
Once that was discovered,
he could help them improve their mental health and to move away from thoughts of
suicide.
As the 20th century progressed,
Frankel shed his ideas beyond this prince media.
He appeared on television to discuss his ideas,
bringing them to an entirely new audience.
In one of his most famous television appearances,
he expounded on his idea that's in the search for life's meaning.
One must have a balance of freedom and responsibility.
During the discussion.
He advocated for the United States to have a partner monuments for the statue of
Liberty.
The country should be book ended with a statue of responsibility on the west
coast.
He argued freedom,
however,
is not the last word.
Freedom is only part of the story in half of the truth.
Freedom is,
but the negative aspects of the whole phenomenon who's positive aspect is
responsibleness.
In fact,
freedom is in danger of degenerating and Zamir arbitrariness unless it is lived
in terms of responsibleness.
That is why I recommended that the Statue of Liberty on the east coast to be
supplemented by a statue of responsibility on the west coast,
answering letters and doing interviews.
Frankel continue to share his message and teach the world about his theories of
psycho analysis.
Right up until his death in 1992 and one of his last interviews,
Frankel Maze,
the poignant observation that even looking back decades later,
you could still find value in his suffering of the concentration camps as he saw
it.
The suffering gave him a valuable perspective on what real trouble is making him
more appreciative of the life that he could live from 1946 onward.
What I would have given then if I could have no greater problem that I face
today.
He sad
when he was in the concentration camps.
Viktor Frankl lived out the idea that he later imparted to the weld in man's
search for meaning.
Everything can be taken from a man,
but one thing the last of the human freedoms to choose one's attitude in any
given set of circumstances to choose one's own way.
While he was in the concentration camps,
Viktor Frankl opted to think his wife to think of his profession,
to theorize about how he could use his experience with suffering to impact
other's lives.
He stole a paper from the camp offices to jot down his ideas and his knew that
he had two reasons to make it out alive love and a responsibility to help people
find meaning and avoid what he calls the existential stress of living without
meaning from the [inaudible] was a student's.
Frankl was helping to save lives.
Though he could have saved the lives of his closest family,
he was able to persevere through unimaginable horrors and spends the next five
decades making a positive impact on the world.
Viktor Frankl,
he could've given up.
He could have died.
He could have lived the rest of his life,
bitter from what he had to go through.
No one would have blamed him,
but instead,
his life has touched millions.
His book has been translated into 74 languages,
and he's impacted generations of new psychotherapists who will spend their lives
helping people.
Viktor Frankl,
a life lived with meaning.
Indeed.
So I really hope you found that video heartwarming.
I found that a particularly inspiring one.
If you did like it,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
And don't forget to subscribe for more videos just like this every Monday and
every Thursday.
So hit that subscribe button.
And as always,
thank you for watching.